the inequality produced by liberty this
for the socialist in Latin America is
the soft underbelly of pro-market
rationale and the best place to attack I
would argue that it is the intellectual
stream that prevails in Latin America
and it's the reason the region cannot
hope to meet its potential anytime soon
I write on a variety of topics for the
editorial page but I have a special
interest in Latin America which is I
think vastly under covered in the
American press so having an audience to
talk to about my views on the region is
really a welcome thing latin america on
paper has as much promise and potential
as its english-speaking hemispheric
neighbors to the north and yet obviously
we know that it lags behind and in my 16
years at the Wall Street Journal I have
spent way too much time trying to figure
out why that is so but tonight I'm going
to share with you some of what I've
learned and of course hopefully with the
humility that David talked about last
night and also recognizing that it's
dangerous to oversimplify any of the
complex problems that are that challenge
the region the fashionable explanations
for Latin American under development are
things like corruption lack of education
poor infrastructure and of course income
inequality of course I reject those I
think those are symptoms of a bigger
problem I think the region's economic
woes are better explained by what I like
to call the three P's populism
protectionism and prohibition even those
are a byproduct of something that I
think is much more fundamental that's
gone wrong in the region and I ask you
just to focus for a minute on two things
first to borrow a cliche that everybody
here is very aware of ideas matter and
second that without entrepreneurship
a society cannot achieve prosperity
that's just a fact you need
entrepreneurs in your economy and if you
dig deeply enough you will find that
ideas from academia and from
intellectuals more broadly in the region
have played the key role in undermining
the entrepreneurial culture in Latin
America over the last century I think
more than anything else this is struck
at the heart of property rights and
prosperity for hundreds of millions of
Latin Americans now many of us are
probably in this room are probably not
fans of John Maynard Keynes but it has
to be accepted that on some issues he
understood the world very well listen to
this quote and probably a number you are
familiar with it it's from the very last
chapter of general theory of employment
interest and money which was of course
his signature work this is what he wrote
the ideas of economists and political
philosophers both when they are right
and when they are wrong are more
powerful than is commonly understood
indeed the world is ruled by little else
practical men who believe themselves to
be quite exempt from any intellectual
influence are usually the slaves of some
defunct economist mad men in authority
we know some of those who hear voices in
the air are distilling their frenzy from
some academic scribbler of a few years
back I am sure that the power of vested
interests is vastly exaggerated compared
to the gradual encroachment of ideas I
agree with canes on this and I think the
evidence overwhelmingly supports his
view Latin Americans as most of you
probably know you probably have
neighbors and friends from the region
have no problem being
oriol immigrants to the US have a long
history of starting their own businesses
once they've landed America so how come
they don't display these skills at home
I submit to you it is because the
dominant ideas in the region over the
last century have been hostile to
entrepreneurship now this jumped out at
me as i said i've been writing about the
region for 16 years but it really made
me focus last summer when i reviewed a
new book by the mexican historian
enrique Krauss II called Redeemers and
subtitled ideas and power in Latin
America the book profiles 12 individuals
who Kraus a believes represent the major
political ideas in the region from the
middle of the 19th century through the
20th century he starts with Jose Marti
and ends with Hugo Chavez he includes
profiles on Ava Peron Che Guevara
Octavio Paz Gabriel Garcia Marquez
Bishop Samuel Ruiz and Subcomandante
Marcos actually of the 12 people he
profiles only one of them is a liberal
that's Mario Vargas Llosa and when I was
reading the book I kept wondering where
during all this time were the the
entrepreneurs the merchants the
architects the builders the creator's
the innovators of Latin America every
society has them why didn't they impose
their own ideas in the region and the
answer I believe is just as Cannes wrote
that the intellectuals were the ones
running things and their ideas of the
time were overwhelmingly hostile toward
entrepreneurship profits and private
ownership now the power of ideas was
well understood among intellectuals on
the left throughout the 20th century and
they said about to get control of
academia in many ways they succeed
as evidenced by what is taught or at
least what prevails in institutions of
higher learning in the region and those
of you who know or knew Musso allow it
was one of the founders of Francisco
marroquín in Guatemala know very well
that musos motivation for starting the
university was he was very frustrated
with the lack of development and
progress in Guatemala and he recognized
that if somehow the people who believed
in freedom and private property and
ownership and profits did not get some
kind of an influence in academic circles
they were never going to change the
country I think it's reasonable to argue
that the ideas of the left gained more
credence in in Latin America than they
did in the u.s. because the left was
more successful in getting control of
education venezuelan-born journalist
Carlos ball who now lives in the United
States has written that after 40 years
he wrote about this when shot around the
time that Chavez was first elected after
40 years of far left controls of schools
universities and the arts in Venezuela
the general public had quote fallen
under a well-organized system of leftist
indoctrination now those sound like
clichés but if you go to Venezuela you
it really is impossible to deny I mean
that's basically how the society has
been educated trained and and how it
thinks and it wasn't only Venezuela this
was true throughout the region as
Enrique Krause he shows and redeemers
forces opposed to classical liberalism
working in the name of Latin nationalism
and much of that nationalism i should
add Krause a believes came from kind of
a backlash against the spanish-american
war and a kind of a feeling that the
u.s. was imposing itself on the region
so there was this Latin nationalism and
that unleashed among intellectuals very
early in the 20th century
anti-americanism that was attached to
sort of anti markets
point of view this intellectual tendency
in favor of nationalism and nationalisms
economic counterpart socialism were
given a big boost during the Great
Depression when the smoot-hawley tariff
hit the region latin american policy
makers retaliated by closing Latin
American markets and for those who had
resisted until then American
protectionism made it more and more
difficult for them to defend defend
their positions of course today the
ideas of Che Guevera and Ava Peron which
are as Hayek told us rival social
factions are not popular and by this i
mean you know communism and fascism but
there are many people who still argue in
favor of collectivism and those people
seldom attack private enterprise head on
I think they know that that's suicidal
because they know that the market has
created so much prosperity but instead
they recognize that the market is
created prosperity and they asked us not
to look at the wealth of nations but
instead what they call the morality or
perhaps more accurately the immorality
of the inequality produced by Liberty
this for the Socialists in Latin America
is the soft underbelly of pro-market
rationale and the best place to attack I
would argue that it is the intellectual
stream that prevails in Latin America
and it's the reason the region cannot
hope to meet its potential anytime soon
this idea that somehow we all have to be
made equal is the prevailing sentiment
across all populations because of the
way people are educated now there are
plenty of reasons that it can't work
reasons that involve the relationship
between risk-taking incentives profits
and rising living standards and of
course there's also a strong moral
argument against empowering the state to
erase inequality but the trouble is that
Latin American intellectuals brought
this idea of equality as the highest
goal
from their ivory towers to daily life
through the region's constitutions and
this I think is really the the principal
problem for a lot of the the countries
in the region latin america is on this
path to poverty but it's finally
impossible to get off because of the
Constitution's which are perpetually
rewritten by the academic and the
intellectual elite to make
state-sponsored equality the law and of
course who can object to the goal to
make it law that the poor child is going
to have as much as the wealthy
entrepreneur but here's the problem with
the constitution written with the
objective of creating equality
fundamentally it cannot guarantee
individual rights and that means that
that you can't have prosperity because
you can't have it both ways Latin
American constitutions are hundreds of
pages long they have objectives like
guaranteeing National Development
eradicated poverty and substandard
living conditions reducing social and
regional inequalities promoting
well-being years ago I reviewed the 1988
Brazilian Constitution and found that
citizens have constitutional right to
education health work leisure security
social security protection of motherhood
and childhood and assistance to the
destitute the 1988 Constitution
guaranteed rights to minimum salaries
year-end bonuses overtime and vacation
pay they are guaranteed free assistance
for children and dependence from birth
to 6 years of age in daycare centers and
preschool facilities the culture section
of the Brazilian Constitution charges
the government with protecting Brazil's
cultural heritage by means of
inventories registers vigilance monument
protection degrees expropriation and
other forms of precaution and
preservation and there's even a section
dedicated to sports where the
Constitution specifies that the
government shall
courage leisure as a form of social
promotion now if you think about all
this enshrined in a constitution you can
easily see that the government not only
has the power but it has the obligation
to use coercion to reach its goals and
this is the fundamental problem a lack
of Liberty which emanates from
constitutional mandates that intrude on
every aspect of human action now I just
want to say been picking on the
intellectuals I want to say one thing
about the business community all of
these problems I think start with the
intellectuals but they would not have
grown out of out of control the way they
have if not for the fact that the
business community joined in very
enthusiastic because he thought there
were benefits for for themselves and
again let's take the case of Venezuela
the 1961 Venezuelan Constitution was by
most accounts a fairly reasonable
document but that didn't mean that
factions as Madison might have called
them didn't have reason to try to pick
it apart and they did for 40 years the
Constitution was under assault
particularly private property rights of
course the left wanted undermine the
rule of law and property rights but the
business community helped and again I'm
going to quote Carlos ball who's written
a lot about this and in fact he wrote in
the journal that the circumstances that
brought Hugo Chavez to power the
so-called democracy and its attendant
business interests did not defend
against the salts on liberty and private
property and this brought about much
injustice and poverty so they sort of
created this situation that when Chavez
came to power people felt very
dissatisfied with the status quo here's
what mr. ball wrote about the slow
deterioration of property rights in the
nineteen sixty one Constitution it's
really frightening many in the business
community did not rebounce growing state
intrusion because they saw that it was
easier to can
Vince one cabinet minister than a market
of consumers I'll never forget watching
Venezuelan businessmen cheering the
nationalization of foreign oil companies
not realizing that the politicians would
soon come after them with more controls
regulations and taxes close quote and as
we know the government of oovoo chavez
subsequently has done much worse when
the state gets the moral high ground in
matters of personal decisions and
property rights there's no end to the
steps that it will take to contain
Liberty in the name of equality once
this happens the standard of living will
necessarily decline I think that's what
explains why the region is stuck in
poverty and unfortunately i don't feel
terribly optimistic about anything
changing anytime soon thank you what do
you see as the role or the significance
of Hernando de Soto and his book the
other path and the other work that he
has done for sure was important but I i
think you know you you see what's
happening in Peru and I mentioned in the
beginning that protectionism populism
and prohibition are three of the biggest
challenges to the region and I think
what Peru managed to do in the years
after that book came out and and you
know they tried to change the country
they opened the economy that's the most
important thing that they didn't prove
that's the thing that's really changing
the country is still a huge amount of
corruption terrible you know abuse of
government power and so forth but the
country is more open and that's force
the state to to contract a little bit
and under the sota also in his book
wrote that the reason Latin Americans
are poor and their governments don't
work is because of proportional
representation that's a system where
voters cannot vote for individual
congressman they vote for party lists
Venezuela being a good example every
five years you could only vote the
voters for the people they put out five
years before and the old men running the
party's control the names on the lists
and it's it's a very dysfunctional
system and American exceptionalism Meho
a lot to our Constitution and our system
of federalism its end divided powers but
the proportional representation is not
addressed often and that's the
dysfunctional democracies in the world
Russia another all have this system I
think you're absolutely right i mean the
kind of the poster child of this is
argentina where the paradise just
continue every election with this with
with power because of that proportional
representation but but i think that's
again that's like a symptom of a broader
problem which I mean we know the problem
is too much government to too much the
government has too much power how does
it get that power it gets it through the
way the politicians make laws and often
times through the Constitution so you
know when the governor was here earlier
talking about what he had done I mean
the amazing thing about Governor fortuño
is not so much that he said okay
government's too big but that he was
able to actually put those reforms in
place and I think the big challenge for
the region is what everyone knows what
creates well there's no mystery about
that it means it's it's kind of it's
almost a scientific thing at this point
but the political you know getting the
political power to force the change is
what the real challenges and I don't
think you get that power that people
become empowered like that unless they
have the right ideas you know you see
people talking about young people being
involved in politics what good is it if
young people are involved in politics
and they're all a bunch of robots and
sent out front you know to vote for
Obama or I mean it's it's useless so
somehow it's the ideas young people have
to be exposed to those ideas if you're
ever going to see change I want to ask
you about a phenomenon
that occurred in the early 1990s in
Latin America there was something after
the collapse of the Soviet Union
something called the Washington
Consensus which seemed to be some
acceptance of privatization of opening
markets and this sort of thing was that
really a flash in the pan I think I
could diagnose the problem by just
looking at the name of it i mean really
is washington going to give us the
answers we need I think the principal
problem with the Washington census I
remember also that people were very
excited about it and the governor was
talking earlier about how crisis
sometimes causes people to pay attention
and of course the Latin American debt
crisis in the 80s they had the Lost
Decade and so they were looking for
ideas and they were trying to come out
of the problem so one of the principal
things was you notice to stop pegging
currencies while you're printing
printing money I mean I don't mind a
fixed fixing your exchange rate to gold
or something like that but you can't be
in the back room making more of it all
the time and that's what they were doing
my principal problem with the Latin
American consensus was that there's
nothing in that plan that talks about
competition nothing it's you know for
example they'd always burn me that they
told these countries to take for example
their telecom companies that were
state-owned monopolies and you'd walk
down the street in Buenos IEDs and you
see all the the wires going across
Florida because they were just in
complete disrepair so he said okay
here's here's the idea you're going to
sell the telephone company to a private
monopoly well personally I rather a
public monopoly because they're easier
to cheat but I'm so they so when you
would present that to them they would
say oh no no because you know if you
sell it as a private monopoly you're
going to get a lot of money for it and
so the government's going to get money
and what's the government going to do
it's going to pay down all the debt and
it's going to build schools and you know
we're going to be prosperous so we need
that money so they went around and they
in almost every country they turned the
public monopoly into a private monopoly
in Argentina one of the main
homes or a main problem with the
convertibility law by the time it went
bust in two thousand was the prices for
telecom were too high because they were
they basically divided the country and
they divided Buenos I ities into two and
they gave to monopolies in each part and
of course we all know about my friend
Carlos Slim in Mexico which who also did
the same thing and so you know he made
this huge amount of money off the backs
of poor Mexicans there was nothing about
competition in in those and what you
ended up with was a bunch of monopolies
in key sectors in the economy those
countries countries could not be
competitive I think that the United
States is actually more than learning
from Latin America I think we're heading
that direction yeah I think yeah and so
what are some ways that you think we
could learn from the myth of this like
Nirvana of equality the late bill
niskanen had a great piece in one of his
books and in fact when he died I don't
know if any of you know bill but he was
at the Cato Institute for many years
wonderful economist and I remember
hearing them as speech he gave many many
years ago but its it's stuck with me he
said you okay imagine you have two
people one guy is a really buff 25
year-old good-looking guy who tends bar
in santa monica and all day long he
plays volleyball John ah and he has a
really good tan and a great bod and and
gets all the girls he wants but he only
makes like you know say twenty-five
thousand thirty thousand dollars a year
the other guy is a paraplegic who spends
every day behind a computer he's
computer programmer I think as bill
described him he was hygienic alii
challenged or something like that didn't
have many dates but um you know was
earning better than six figures and
niskanen used to say how are you going
to make these two people equal and I
just thought that was so power
full you know because of course the
state can make them equal they can move
the money around right but you really
can't make them equal and of course we
know when we're children we we learn
those things that you know that we're
not equal but we're special there's no
one like us and you know that that idea
that you know people really aren't equal
they have all kinds of differences is I
don't know should be I would think
something just fundamental to what we we
teach our children but you know if you
go against that in a public school year
that's a tough challenge I think we need
to get rid of the public schools how's
that part of the problem with American
foreign policy and trade policies that
we really do think that whatever we do
is that causes all things that are good
or bad in the world how can American
policy towards Latin America make things
better if not make things better not
make things worse well any of the drug
wars you know an obvious thing and and
the problem there is just that we've
empowered these huge organized crime
networks that are overwhelming the the
power of the state in place particularly
in Central America it's very bad right
now I have for a long time recommended
three things one to get rid of the IMF
and that's not going to happen i think
that the region has actually done what
my friend David malpass an analyst on
Wall Street who I've known for many
years he used to say you know you're
never going to get rid of that
bureaucracy you just not it's it's to
behaving like a typical bureaucracy but
what countries have to do is learn to go
without them and I think Brazil has has
learned to do that basically and um so
that's that's one thing drug war and
then of course trade I mean I my
favorite recommendation there would just
be unilateral disarmament you know but
our markets and I think that those
countries would open but but at a
minimum you know don't sign a free trade
agreement Columbia and wait like six
years or something like that to ratify
and lastly I mean I think the Fed is a
big problem for the region because you
know our money is not stable and we're
the reserve currency so they're always
trying to figure out how they can it's
very tough to have a trading
relationship when you have this monster
you know kind of controlling exchange
rates so at a minimum the Fed could do a
better job at stabilizing the value of
the dollar and my first choice would be
you know to get rid of the Fed so if you
had a couple New York New Yorker friends
and they come to you one night cocktail
party and they say you know I'm just fed
up I hate the way this country is gone
if Ron Paul doesn't when I'm out of here
and for some reason I want to go to
Latin America's calling me so I think
there's like 17 countries down there
between South America and Central
America where would you recommend the
top three what's your top three list
doesn't sound good when I'm listening to
you but there's got to be you know
there's an idea in Honduras right now
called the charter cities has anybody
been following the charter City idea
yeah so this is an idea sort of right up
your alley maybe you want to join up
it's an idea that's promoted by an
economist that who's now at NYU by the
name of Paul Romer but the idea actually
is sort of homegrown in Honduras they've
figured out that you know to make all
the reforms and changes in the
Constitution that they would need to
make in order to create a liberal
economy would be too much because
they're going to have special interest
fighting them on everything so they said
okay we're going to take a big plot of
government land that's on the sea and
make like a kind of Hong Kong experiment
and so they'll be starting from scratch
there'll be someone to I guess there's
going to be some kind of a sponsor a
tour there make a bunch of laws and then
anybody who can come in who wants to
live by those laws they'll be no minimum
wage laws basically minimum amount of
regulation and they can choose their
currency they're going to be on the port
so they're going to need some
infrastructure development but it's a
fascinating idea and actually in
erns have the idea that they would try
to start at least a couple of these
because you know one might be badly
managed and if it fails then people are
going to say all that idea can't work
but if you have four or five and they
have to compete like if you had
competition in the in the early 90s then
you have a better chance for success I
think it's a fascinating idea and my
friend Giancarlo ebar Gwen who's the
rector at ma tokine now it just loves it
I mean he's very enthusiastic about it
and they've held a couple of conferences
on it so that's called charter cities
you might want to follow that Mary
reading over the years I think you
recognize all the problem is that drugs
have a broad to Latin America but you've
never been an advocate of the simple
solution of ending prohibition do you
think you're going to come around to
that at some point what how can you say
that I am an advocate of ending
prohibition well that was the simple
answer all right on that note thank you
so much
you know let me just let me just say one
thing about that it kind of gets to the
point you know when I was listening to
David last night talk about tolerance
and humility and you know I've tried
very hard to understand the fears I
think that there are a lot of special
interests involved in the drug war
obviously you know there's a huge
industry in Washington of helicopter
manufacturers and people who chase these
guys around the jungle forever and so
there there are a lot of special
interest but i think that there's also a
legitimate part of the population that's
afraid of what this means and what I've
tried to do in my columns is rather than
say to them tisk tisk tisk you know
don't you understand you know that
prohibition is bad and you know can't
you why are you so uptight you know what
I've tried to do is get them to
understand that okay let's let's call
this a bad thing all right let's say we
don't want it okay how are we going to
manage this vise that we have this thing
that we want to minimize in our society
what's the best way to do it and so what
I try to say my column is think about
the costs of the current of the status
quo think about what that is because I
think a lot of people who you know I
think in general if you have referendums
and so forth so far most people would
would be against for example legalizing
cocaine but most people don't live with
the consequences of what our war on
drugs in Colombia has done so what I've
tried to do in my column is have a
conversation with people so that they
start to appreciate that this is not a
cost-free policy that is just good for
them and there's no and and doesn't hurt
anybody else it's hurting someone else
and if they would see it in that larger
light I think that they would start to
understand that we need a policy change
that's why I don't write columns that
say we have to end prohibition but
rather say look this isn't working can
we at least agree that this is not
working that drugs are readily available
and at the under
consequences are very high for innocent
people have nothing to do with the drug
war let's try to agree on that and then
I think you know we can take further
steps and that's that's why you don't
read me wagging my finger okay yeah
alright with that we're going to wrap up
thank you so much